a week since the undignified collapse of
boris johnson's government he was back
in the chamber for his first prime
minister's questions since agreeing to
go but first there was an unusual and
chaotic start
neil hamby i am now naming you and kenny
mccaskill to leave this chamber shall i
just deal with them deal with them
think about sergeant
two mps thrown out for protesting in the
chamber when it did come to the prime
minister he was perhaps not his usual
buoyant self so soon after being ousted
by his own party but he was colorful in
his criticism of labor
i think if possible mr speaker he's
referring uh not to me uh but uh some of
the eight brilliant candidates who are
currently buying uh for my job
any one of them would wipe the floor
with captain crasher rooney's snoozefest
and after a few weeks time
that is exactly what they will do they
will unite around the winner and do just
that
and the prime minister was definitely in
legacy making mode
and it's perfectly true it's perfectly
true that i leave not at a time of my
choosing and i will be leaving mr
speaker
i will be leaving soon with
my head held high
[Music]
with the leadership race underway labour
were keen to broaden their criticism
onto the man who may well replace boris
johnson
i really am going to miss this weekly
nonsense from him
let's move on from his current
chancellor to his former chancellor
last week he resigned
yesterday
he claimed his big plan
is to rebuild the economy now even the
prime minister must be impressed by that
johnson brass neckery
and the mood on the tory benches was
notably rowdier today last week's stony
faces replaced by loud cheers when the
prime minister arrived
yes
on the new look front bench some of
those hoping to replace boris johnson
can i say on behalf of the people of red
car in cleveland how grateful we are for
the support that he's given us can i
thank the prime minister for delivering
brexit and the fantastic vaccine rollout
program
can i thank the prime minister for all
he's done to help level up
stoke-on-trent i would like to first
send the huge thanks for your support to
ukraine boris johnson is due to appear
opposite starmah for the last time next
week but today a strange hint that this
could be his last pmqs the next leader
of the of my party may be elected by
acclimation so it's possible this will
be our last our last confrontation over
this just
it's possible so i want to thank him
i want to thank him for the style in
which he's conducted himself i think
it'd be fair to say he's been
considerably less lethal than many other
members of this house
the loyally labour leader and the
unconventional boris johnson it is hard
to imagine two more different opponents
the noise was certainly back on the tory
benches today but the fight to save
boris johnson is over and labour may
well soon be facing a very different
kind of opponent